you
hey this is Jeff clima for new media
rockstars i'm sitting here with two of
the biggest stars in the internet world
the fellows of charlie bit my finger and
i'm super excited to talk with you guys
like i said you guys are probably about
the two biggest stars in viral video so
that's exciting now how are you guys
doing today hello my good good yeah all
right now which one of you is Harry and
which one of you is Charlie I'm Johnny
I'm hurry okay i knew that i just wanted
to see if you guys did it was a test you
guys pass good work now how old are you
guys now I'm 6 and I'm 80 ms 9 a change
to my neck eight days til I'm nine hey
days while coming up here huh all right
now what have you guys been up to since
the charlie bit my finger came out yes
tell me lots of filming what all right
what have you guys been filming mmm us
can't the wing nice exciting good stuff
all around huh ready gang I'm excited to
see the new videos so now of all the
videos you guys have been filming like
what has been your favorite so far mmm
yeah I like to ask the tough questions
I'm tricky that was awesome yeah I think
awesome that you did which chosen to do
was it didn't last week in the gun the
molasses is exceeded your king of the
week yeah the whole six was it glued
what the charlie bit me show the whole
set yes does it cool john berry sure he
didn't pay the treaty sure hmm okay all
right a little do so did you guys at
least have fun making those shows oh my
little bit young um
quite not quite a lot okay so we got a
lot in a little bit okay that's good
that's good you guys are synched up on
that I like that all right well what was
your favorite part that of making the
new shows like did you guys like being
newsreaders the best or did you like
being the Kings the best or do you like
playing and rating the the new toys
playing hey a good call I hear you guys
just got the new Nintendo it so are you
guys gonna play that there's a Nintendo
game or whatever sorry you guys gonna
play as soon as you get off the
interview with me yes okay good good you
gonna play all through dinner forget
dinner and just eat play video games ya
know cuz we kind of wind pains Oh are ya
nice what do you like it Wimpy's okay
good god milkshake vocal about boku
about me since watch of ketchup and
chips and you can't go yeah right oh you
guys are in big into the chips and
ketchup yeah oh good me too what kind of
milkshakes you guys like chocolate yeah
chocolate and banana now do you guys
ever collaborate I have chocolate banana
oh you what I hate no no no you hate
banana okay said yeah but Anna's are
kind of healthy they're not the most fun
thing in the world I can agree with that
haha so now do you guys you guys ever
get recognized in public yep yeah you
guys are pretty famous a lot of people
stalking you on the street saying hi
Nene no that's good but your classmates
recognize you and stuff yep yes are they
cool about you guys being super famous
you what if you teenagers in the pod few
teenagers in the park what are those
teenagers doing in the park those guys
are crazy huh name no that's good that's
what they should be doing let's hope you
AJ they was nice nice so you guys just
got out of school huh yep oh man are you
guys ready for the weekend super excited
yeah yeah I got crazy big plans look at
that Charlie he's got big plans now do
you do you still bite him at all or
are you what yes I did I Triton bother
listen it's very hot now okay you guys
got it you gotta keep a regular so
pretty I better he doesn't okay what's
the best thing about being recognized do
you guys think mmm fun it's fun to be
recognized yeah the beep do you have to
sign autographs and stuff like that well
it's why it's kind of tedious to penius
is a big word I should probably it's
kind of a is it a pain in the butt to to
be recognized sometimes no you never
it's always awesome you guys right
around saloons miss Dawson it isn't
awesome oh why wasn't it's a pain no I
didn't do pain okay it's not a pain but
it's not awesome so it's somewhere in
the middle yes good fun huh sometimes
embarrassing embarrassing wife wanted I
don't know yeah it's one of those things
like I like this guy is making the
invisible phone call that's good good
work Charlie play that all right so so
there's nothing too embarrassing nothing
too crazy it's pretty good it's a good
gig is what you're saying oh yeah nice
there we go that's the enthusiasm I like
yes oh then you what gene what do I mean
that it's a I don't know what I mean I
just like to talk i'm one of those
grown-ups that talks all the time so I'd
rather be a kid and play video games you
guys seem like you have it pretty good
Oh bull ring talking is boring yes I
agree and I'm probably like I'm kind of
a boring adult there we go get close to
the kitten look I'll do that to you
eating the free kick you guys are much
more handsome than I am I'm kind of
creepy looking i got this wire coming
out of my ear hahahahaha this is the
kind of interview I like to do good work
guys you're making it entertaining
normally I have to talk to other boring
grown ups you guys are interesting you
got a bear on your shirt I think that's
pretty cool so doing my gosh now you
guys are the biggest you guys are the
biggest viral video stars out there
you think of fruits grain you want me to
put my bigger to the screen boom oh oh I
just got a head butted Charlie look at
that Charlie head-butted me and now he's
biting me oh you're biting me I like it
you got a gimmick this is good hey so
there we go nicely done I have now been
officially skype bitten by Charlie I
could deal with that a great date you
guys are fun I like you guys so this is
cool we should hang out all the time so
not too much though you could get weird
but now you guys music videos are the
only thing on YouTube more popular than
you two guys yeah blue on the music
videos well what do you think you guys
think of you guys would make a music
video one day yeah yeah never never yes
rubbish that's exactly the way I think
about those yeah bevo down with VEVO
right good call so just big FIFA and
baby Golf ah yeah yeah nice I hope I
never have to interview them cuz I'll
have to tell him you guys said that so
what do you guys want to be when you
grow up I know hey you want to be police
he won't sweetly some woman what's the
police woman okay it's not alright so
and what about what about you Harry any
night night isn't builder night done Oh
busted you want to be a builder I dude
all right I'll see if we'll see if you
become a builder i'll be like I remember
when you didn't want to be one so all
right well what are some other videos
you guys do like on YouTube then did you
say I got he look hmm you say what did I
say i SAT there and I said what are some
other videos you guys do like I'm
youtube if you don't like Justin Bieber
and baby gaga hmm you guys like
raywilliamjohnson stuff like that or no
yeah good call yeah that guy gonna take
him down all right well you guys have a
third brother right named Jasper yes
okay now
wasn't born yet when you guys made the
first video right yeah okay now but he's
in the new videos right yes is that
pretty fun or is he a cool little
brother is he kind of a pain so what
does that equal what is that equal and
equals three I count three brothers
right yeah is there a hidden fourth
brother we don't know about you got full
breakfast it they got soul you have four
brothers brothers we go oh brother ok
well there's money who's the its Jasper
you Charlie and Lissa Rupert see I
didn't even know about Rupert this is
exciting i feel like i'm breaking a big
story here how old is Rupert 10 man so
there's a new one of you guys my
goodness is he gonna make a bit you guys
gonna get him to bite your finger too no
no oh my head finger all right well I'll
tell you what you guys can go play the
video games I'll tell you last question
do you guys have any cool Christmas
plans oh yes okay good oh the planets in
the world only three boys that's a
pretty good Christmas plan I'd say now
you guys it's kind of like Christmas
anyway though right cuz you always get
new toys and stuff to review so you guys
are you guys are constantly getting
excited I like him yeah Harry you're the
more sensual reserved one that Charlie
and me we're kind of crazy I respect
that all right well tell you what you
guys go play those video games you guys
go to Wimpy's get a milkshake for me
make it easy on guys yes say goodbye
just roll like goodbye hey you know
singing bad bye bye thank you guys very
much to you guys are awesome okay all
right I'll talk to you later
bye
Oh
Oh